did you ever see him fight so my father
i have a saying i have a saying which is
my most famous saying i say i said at
the end of the final video my unmatched
perspective coupled with sheer and
difficulty ability makes me a fear
opponent in any realm of human endeavor
and for the people watching it means
unmatched perspective your ability to
perceive and understand the world pay
attention to things and take in all the
different variables pay attention
because while a lot of people don't
coupled with indefinite ability the
ability to never become tired
makes you a feared opponent in any realm
of human endeavor so if you pay
attention to everything and you analyze
the chess board correctly and you never
give up
it doesn't matter if you're trying to
climb mount everest doesn't matter if
you're trying to escape a social media
ban you're a dangerous guy he doesn't
quit and he pays a bunch of attention
that that's a guy you don't want as an
enemy and my father said that i heard my
father say that the story behind it is
we were in detroit my father was a world
level chess player
he was an amazing man but he was to a
degree a flawed man let's say he likes
to gamble my father's attitude towards
life is something i've also adopted
because i've even said it myself i
either want to be filthy rich or flat
broke i feel like slavery's in between
and i i said to my brother when we had
no money let's just move to thailand
let's just move to thailand and fight
and just live on 50 bucks a day and just
run around the beach and have our time
back like what are we slaving away a job
to pay the rent and then we're broke i'd
rather be i either have to feel like i'm
going to make it right just quit
capitalism yeah i don't want to be in
between
and my father was the same so he he won
a chess tournament a low level one he
made like three thousand dollars or
something and he said listen son
the rent's paid and i i either 100 grand
or nothing
it's just who i am so
we went to the casino lost all the money
casino's a bad place to go and try and
get rich but that's my dad lost all the
money so then we were in detroit and we
were hustling in a park my dad was a
chess park hustler he'd go into the
parks
and he'd sit down and say you all get 10
minutes i get a minute on the clock and
you play 10 games simultaneously while
they had 10 minutes each and he'd have a
minute and he'd sit there and just
just smoke them all for money right and
take all the money in so uh and we'll
talk about world double chess players
because i'll make it clear
i do not have the intellect to be a
world of chess player even though i have
the genetics it's something you're born
with it's kind of like being a human
calculator it's something in your brain
you can't train it's like learning to
sing you can learn to sing but you're
not gonna be mariah carey unless you're
born with it right the way his mind
worked was a different level of
intellect and i i don't possess it and
that's a blessing and a curse because
i'm better socially than he was he was
not very sociable as a person and in
these high-level chess tournaments a lot
of them are not very sociable people and
we can talk about that at length but
so we made some money and we went to a
gas station in detroit and i remember
this vividly i was about eight or nine
years old i went to the back to the
coolers i opened to get a drink and i
heard all this noise
and when i turned around my dad was
fighting three men
and
i don't know how the fight started i
don't know where it came from he had one
of them up against the door and he he
had him up like this and he was biting
his face
and the other two are punching my dad in
the back of the head
and i'm a kid
and i just stood there like
the [ __ ] and the korean guy behind us
shouting stop stop stop stop and i'm
standing there and i went i didn't know
what to do so i kind of went to walk
over and although my dad was getting
punched although he was biting this guy
i remember him turning to me and saying
stay there
and went back to biting the i don't know
the [ __ ] to this day i don't know how
the fight started
korean guy came around the back kind of
got in the middle did the the guys went
out they threatened to kill him we're
gonna [ __ ] kill you like gangbangers
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] you my dad had blood
all over his face some from the guy some
from him his eye was black his eye
socket got fractured his eye was closed
he bumps heads up
so we stood there and the korean guy
started panicking saying my store
damaged my store wait please wait please
wait police and i think my dad was a bit
disoriented he never went down but i
could tell he was a bit dizzy so my dad
stood there and he stood he stood like
this like in like military positions
stood in the corner of the place and
wait for the police officer to come and
the police officer came
and start doing reports ask what
happened start talking to reports etc
and the police officer said to my dad
so you've fought these three guys he
goes okay well
what's your job
my dad said i'm a chess player
and the police officer said well
maybe you should have been something
else
and my dad said my unmatched perspective
coupled with sheer individuality makes
me a feared opponent in any realm of
human endeavor
i remember him saying that was his
answer to the police officer the police
officer was like
yeah how do you spread it
bro
yeah and that was a saying that my dad
started using then on after and i adopt
i adopted so um that's the only time i
ever saw him fight if you enjoyed this
video and you want to watch the entire
podcast click over here and if you want
to be connected with experts influencers
such as kiyosaki tate connolly
palmentary myself and others download
the app minect where you get a chance to
connect with these folks by the minute
you get to buy the minute or have face
times with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you may want to have download
the app connect and start connecting
with influencers and experts today
you